yeah dating another comic field who's on
the road all the time then you guys
wiped me back here when you got sets at
night what are you gonna do yeah yeah
I've thought about it something updated
a little bit here and there within the
industry but yeah well I'll tell you
this I mean so yesterday I go to these
adult meetings sometimes for adults and
uh what do you mean just like adult
means where people get together spend
time together like a a mmm if it's a a
really buddy CIA bro in there vacant
he's always very like it's very dating
these adult meetings you talk about a a
I don't drink so I'll say that anyway
girl right I met this sweet gal that I
didn't see I seen it for a couple of
weeks really been long and for probably
in my brain right long so I get her name
I get her a get her number yesterday
right well then some straight up skis
some girl just throwing that butt around
on snapchat right send meanest says I
don't have your number right so I give
her my number on snapchat alone at home
and the evening I'm lonesome I give this
girl my number you don't have any food
and there I have a little bit of a
London broil meat okay and I uh
yeah and just me and we're eating just
me your brain gets real limbic you know
you drop into a primal time you know
limbic just that London broil - that
ain't the fancy stuff it's not real it's
a tougher end of it scrapple it's a
scrapper it's the hip but what happened
was so then the snapchat girl text I
when I got the girl's number that I
really think like might have been the
one oh yeah I got her number and I just
put my name in and I texted her my name
right in front of right that way boom
there's nothing creepy about that
nothing crazy I'm natural normal I was a
gentleman in the conversation
everything was good I'll see you later
young she'll you know and then though
later so the snapchat girl text me
I thought she texted me it wasn't it was
the girl that I liked a few hours later
wrote I'm gonna put you inside here I'll
read
this this is the thirsty snapchat grow
this hey this is not real life no but
the thirsty snapchat girl texted me
thought it was the one that he likes
right well this is uh this is the girl
who are liked texting me back
I thought the thirsty snapchat girl was
texting me ah this is already already
back
she wrote cool you are going in my
rolodex right that's what she wrote so I
thought it's a snapchat girl she'd ask
me for my number I said I want to go in
more than that
creeping yeah turning heads and I'll
tell you what it is man I'm alone by
myself at night and I'm just rock-hard
got there that's a bet to go not
rock-hard soft and cotton and just
agitate it lonely wait so now that worst
thing you can head London broad I did
have a yogurt too but I was saving that
for later that was gonna be like my
nighttime a [ __ ] look at me a nighttime
cab adventure he said so what happened
what she responds he wrote do tell go on
oh so now I think it's definitely now I
have no song now in my head no I have no
doubt it's a snapchat girl I don't think
it's a snapchat girl yeah I have not
brought to the realization that this is
the girl that I otherwise she's into it
she's game maybe that's a game was my
baby who tell go I go I want being more
than that maybe she's thinking oh yeah
I'm seeing a nice dinner maybe a steak
in it maybe a kiss not a dick son yeah
maybe I want to peel that rump apart too
much too much
why don't I wanna so anyway as I'm
picking a little bit of London we're all
out of my mouth dude and feeling
probably with meat in your mouth you
feel more carnivorous and also more you
know I got this yeah tribal tribal
yeah tribal dude how to pet try on your
primal primal trial probably drive there
you go primal she goes do tell go on I
said inside of your body right cuz I
want to go in more than that I feel like
you're better than that
the can oh I do you could have been a
little more descriptive
oh this isn't me doing this this is the
dark arts that are inside of me coming
out and now doesn't mean a black man in
a theatre that means the other side of
it where you're a bow design yeah just
just me feeling lonesome and B&R Sam I
might be dating pretty soon because I'm
liking this whole connection are similar
that
she's European yeah addis ababa i
something i d-- survival one-time yeah
nice people there had some good uh
flatbread let me finish this up so then
i said i want to go in more than that so
she goes do tell go on I said inside of
your body then wherever you want me
that's what I creep in with it this line
right she goes wow that's how you roll
huh wasting no time so at this point I'm
like why would the snapchat girl say
that you know she just showing me like
pictures of her bud and like yeah which
is a dirty bedroom yeah alright and then
I'm like oh my god I'm so sorry I just
realized who this was I don't even know
what to say and that's when we had a
conversation about it
well that's could you explain the
situation I try but here's the
explanation so here's the thing I
thought you were this raging [ __ ] who's
gonna come over here this London broil
and I was gonna [ __ ] you yeah but right
turns out you're actually really nice
and I probably this is the really yeah I
like you and I'm gonna put on an act and
I would have taken you out to dinner and
kind of bought you drinks and who knows
what could have led to I don't know what
those that over nude she was actually
super cool like we texted for a while I
explained myself some so why are you
beating yourself up so she still likes
you right she still likes me but the
root of the issue is still um I am a
two-sided individual where I'm well I
think most people are but I was right
because that snapchat girl that whose
twerked and shown that ass and with the
dirty room like that dirty shirt
insurance you know that's easy pic or
stream like I that's Google type
something nasty
yeah that's not you you know that's not
a real relationship yeah sure I get them
rocks off meet someone embroil that's
right yeah meanwhile you got this lady
who classy lady I like the fact she's
like Jesus Christ man yes the she get
too graphic
were you really grossed her out well the
crazy part was at one just take pic goon
Oh game over yes well I don't Simone
dick pics I got a buddy I use his dick
pic there's Jason Tebow you know him
Jason teba Comedy Store in comedian he's
got she's um he's with uh
triply uh he's a yeah he's got it we got
a see some people sighs dick get
something get yours
a nice hat a nice background yeah okay
so take that green color background but
I use his I used a bad idea that's a
brilliant idea
yeah it's not bad your dicks not out
thinking it feels much shame and then
you you've got it's decent piece out
there in the atmosphere you got to live
up to it that problem yeah make sure
it's similar to yours I can't send some
[ __ ] Panther tail and then show up
with it you know yeah have an off day
sorry Lego piece so anyway yeah I guess
you're right dude may I beat myself up
for yourself oh yeah you know that
there's a dark side to all of us where
sometimes yeah I'll be honest with you
like there's the girl you date the girl
you marry and there's the one you bring
home to mom that's right and then
there's the girl that you have kids with
but then there's the girl that sometimes
just gets you going for example if I see
a girl in a shitty sports car with
something hanging from the rearview
mirror like dice or some [ __ ] and really
yeah fake nails with bad makeup eyeliner
big mouth I'm tree that's the kind of
girl that to me couple butterscotches on
the - yeah well like hell yeah a couple
of butterscotch on the dashboard now
that that that sends me that taps into
my dark side we do know white because
you wouldn't mind running a train on
that girl with your body but if she took
that do why are you trying to get why
she's trying to rest for are we call my
Ferraro's [ __ ] got her she's in a
old-school Maserati maybe a Datsun I
don't know sir say that's right like
what you're saying doc but you would but
you don't anybody in a Toyota Tercel why
you starting out boy not my girl I'm
don't know what I'm saying is is let's
say if she was like oh hey old man do
you have a young friend who'd like the
[ __ ] why she pick it out and you would
be like hell yeah
call me up now if this was a girl you
wanna bring home to mom you like hell no
she would never say that she would never
like a boy she would never say that
alright man I guess you just upload your
way in here to my girl my situation
there's a difference between Mary and
then run a train on with your body yeah
why are you in his it's a short trainee
that's a short train to a train
it's a short they're not why are you
bringing these guys and I don't even
know them to see them naked this is a
battle know if that [ __ ] is driving an
old Datsun she's fired down for a
four-hour training with a Korean or she
can't afford a nicer car god dammit why
are you picking on poor people right
bounces wow you guys are basically
outdoor black guys right now you realize
that do you realize that or not and also
it's not running a train if it's just
you in his dream after I said it's my
dream what kind of trainer we talk about
here because she's the caboose I've got
one power in the back one engine in the
front that'd be a train and he's just
not going anywhere I'm just a station
that's two guys trying to weld a caboose
I think welding a caboose yeah it's
called welding the caboose that's in
scott-heron that's a new saying about to
weld this caboose got a welder his
dreams dude I hate to tell you that I
bro you seem like you're doing well and
you're trying to get on to his dreams
shop does very well the shop doesn't cuz
he's got a girl but shop if he wanted to
could clean up although he's clean he
smells good and he's got a career women
love ya he's handsome I love a man I
think if probably man that her feeling
light probably love him as well you know
he's got that Italian are you Italian a
little bit yeah like Greek or whatever
it is right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]